ich hätte auch nur noch zwei herzen hat
nicht entscheiden die erschwert ab wie
denn dieser welt warum sich die ganzen
leute
rss feeds und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge rote top ten
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht ist das
die vierte und wir spielen heute dass
ihr habt es euch gewünscht ich bin jetzt
wie immer die kommentare 1
und ich würde sagen die schon
aufgefallen die stats krass platz 76
schon werden platz 80 erreichen müssen
ist lang erreicht wir können theoretisch
direkt danach die nächste folge
aufnehmen und wenn ich sage wir meine
ich mich und den teig wies christ ich ja
hallo erst sollte zuerst mal in einer
teilweise ist einfach so dass einfach so
die übersetzung zwischen gehirn und
meine zunge einfach so ins gameplay
durchdreht und dann muss ich erstmal so
in mode das war gerade der professor
eckhard aller zeiten und wir haben die
runde gewisse ist es niemandem
aufgefallen nein nein keiner merkt es
bemerkt hat keine pausen des kartoffel
von mir einfach die gpu läuft so läuft
das genau heisst es weiter du kannst hat
leider nicht an der verlosung teilnehmen
weil du hier in der 103 ja das ist echt
doof wie gehst du damit um
ich bin ein bisschen traurig darüber
genauso wie das ich einfach keine chance
wahrte wo bist du ich keine macht den
holzschwert wenigstens einen eltern eine
sache das geht schnell kann sich auch
mal einfach holz ganz schnell man kein
staat machen
ich hab' ich habe es einfach verdient
zwei eisen zu haben sage ich einfach mal
so ich brauche nicht mehr viel ändern
kann nicht
druck entstanden war ich bin direkt auf
essens jahr gegangen trägt auch zu
entscheiden wo gott der und es entstand
ein thema wichtig das bedeutet ich mache
die erdinger du bist ja echt so dass das
geld ein anderer oder ich bin weg
geklatscht ich bin ja da hätte sowas von
hexer der hatte so was von jetzt an
der hat mich mit einem mit einem schlag
hat er mehr als der hälfte leben
abgezogen dass wir selbst am
gleisdreieck support und hat von bogen
ich renne der hat schon so genau wo man
sich so denkt hacker heckhoff hat keinem
erfolg einer vielleicht vielleicht ist
ja ein bisschen dauert ja kann ich das
nicht auch schaffen es einst ein
straßenjunge war das eine option alter
ich wäre einfach ist somit schritt und
auf einmal steht ein typ mit eisen
schwert und besser wüsste und ich kann
einfach nicht
das ist so geil
es ist irgendwie kanal aus london
sotschi hat der gangsta rap und als
richtiger gangster block aus london hat
ja so krass teetrinken gangsta rap und
das ist schon krass
auf jeden fall der bieten so als ich
hier leider nicht erreichen
was bringt eigentlich spion naja weil
diese serie macht mir das immer so die
zuschauer schreibe es in die kommentare
was sie sich wünschen für die nächste
folge an
gespielt wird übrigens an dieser stelle
jetzt der die aufruf der aufruf und die
aufforderung schreibt einfach da die
jetzt in die kommentare welches geht
hier sehen wir in der nächsten folge die
folgen letzten folge mehr gezeigt dass
das ganz gut funktioniert und jetzt
jetzt kommt schon stirbt einfach mal
vorne
der rennt um sein leben visum bernadina
wenn du sagst sagt stimmt laufen
ok ok junge hat den ranger dessen kein
grüner nein aber er war einfach so knapp
hinter mir dass man da nichts machen
konnte
ja dann machen wir jetzt noch ein und
rufen sie uns nicht gleich ist gleicher
spielmodus gleich viele und
lieblingsorte die teams bekommen
danke danke und bitte ich hab auch
indirekt oder direkt in der schweiz
treten wir strikt ab euro vj 747 der us
läufer wir nämlich auch in 27 bild auf
vollbild
es geht nicht mein laptop so richtig
behinderte abmessung und zwar 1362 mal
726 oder so und deshalb müsste dann
deswegen kann ich nicht im vollbild
aufnehmen ich hab es hat lange gedauert
bis ich herausgefunden habe dass finnen
ich fahre jetzt nicht im vollbild
aufnehmen darf weil es uns einfach
scheiß rennen ab aber mittlerweile ist
das so weit wir können jetzt nicht nur
ein dia shows machen sondern auch
richtig böse die akkus das ganz geil so
123 kannst ja auch brote machen für
unterwegs sonst wird man wissen würde
ich sagen okay 1 30 uhr zwischen gegner
kommuniziert was nicken
da sieht uns nicht so jetzt fällt der
erste spieler kümmern so kollege kollege
kollege ja okay jetzt rasch löschen
den ersten habe ich da wird sich auf den
schönen garten schön gehabt geht
spielzeit spion kit immer noch und den
gerade erst gedacht es hat aber lange
gedauert
cameleon ist einfach sooo geil ich war
einfach geile typen der war schwein am
kinn
ich habe ich dann einfach so ich bin ich
schnell hinterher gerannt weil die kiste
am denken zwar so auf einmal habe ich
mir das liegt so damit ich so mit der
kuh als coo so ein bisschen zu genau den
karten auf einmal schlecht so scheiße
wollte halt vielleicht so und ich lag
denn einfach so richtig weg das ist
nicht erschreckt dass rich erstickt ich
spruch du kannst halt richtig geile
sache machen nicht laufen guter tipp
wenn du kamel und spielst es er immer
schicken killen weil schicken hat so
eine winzige hit box also diesen so
schwer zu treffen
deswegen ich würde immer schicken
spielen deshalb so geil wenn sie
geschickt durch die gegentreffer für die
leute gilt ja so ein lustiger anblick
und dann du kannst eine katze hat auch
als chamäleon vielleicht ein bisschen
back ist kannst du auf jeden fall
ullrich geschossen ohne entdeckt werden
und der ist unter der erde nächste bei
der erde 40 blöcke gras ist einfach so
glück was passiert ich bin gestorben
weil ich der hat der hat sieben fälle
von mir kassiert 7 pfeile alle
hintereinander und hatte glaube ich noch
irgendwie ein herz und aber ich hatte
auch nur noch zwei herzen hat mich beim
entscheiden
schwert ab wie denn dieser welt warum
sich die ganzen leute ich hab doch das
fucking spionen kit was bringt die
scheiße denn die sehe mich aber jedes
mal hatte hatte das späte hand nehme ich
habe extra zweites wort freigehalten
mega seltsam mir gesetze überhaupt
keinen überblick
die folge ist aber jolo ich würde sagen
okay versuchen wir mal die
verabschiedete ohne sprache gelernt zu
bekommen so tag wie es ist in der
beschreibung shack team ab las einen
daumen nach oben da möchte die ganze
sache gefallen hat schreibt eure wunsch
kids für die nächste folge in die
kommentare
natürlich sagen haut rein macht es gut
und bis zum nächsten video